having won international recognition for
its handling of the pandemic
and setting standards for testing and
tracing
south korea now struggles to contain
this third wave
it seems earlier successes may have bred
complacency
compounded by pandemic fatigue
overconfidence had grown in many
people's minds and he lowered their
guard
we were relatively successful in dealing
with the first and second outbreaks
and one international praise for it in
south korea's third biggest city incheon
zhang hanaram is one of a team of
tracers who are working around the clock
what makes this surge so hard to control
is how
widespread it is
when i saw all the new confirmed cases
and daily epidemiological survey
i thought wow this is really getting out
of control
ski resorts are now being closed and
private gatherings severely restricted
in
size the ice skating rink that would
normally occupy the space in front of
seoul city hall
non-existent this year seoul has its
christmas tree as usual
but not the normal ceremony for
switching on its lights that was held
online
just one of the many seasonal traditions
south korea
is having to forgo this year families
would normally visit
beaches or national parks to see the
first
sunrise of the new year many of those
have been closed by a government
increasingly concerned by what that new
year will bring
from a pandemic it thought it had under
control
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul